[Music]
this is a special year money briefing
for Friday March 31st I'm J.R Whalen for
the Wall Street Journal my guest today
is Lynette calfani Cox she's a former
financial news journalist author and CEO
of the money coach a financial education
company hey Lynette thank you for being
with us thank you for having me my
pleasure
so Lynette do people often underestimate
the amount of work and preparation that
goes into buying a home I really do
think that the vast majority of
Americans
underestimate not only the amount of
work that it takes to go into buying a
home but what it takes to sustain that
house because sustainable home ownership
is really what it's all about we've seen
obviously in recent years through a
number of financial setbacks and
recessions that we've had that
foreclosures have hit certain people
whether it's due to job losses divorce a
whole bunch of factors and then not to
mention the fact that home prices
themselves have become so Out Of Reach
frankly for a lot of folks all right so
let's talk about getting your ducks in
order before starting the process now
obviously money is going to be a pivotal
part of the process and people might
sort through their finances to figure
out how much house they can afford but
is there more to it than that I do think
there's a lot more than the average
person considers when it comes to
weighing home affordability certainly
the banks are going to give you an
indication of what they think you can
afford but I'm always telling people
that that's really not the true
barometer that you should use a bank is
going to ask you about your DTI or your
debt to income ratio they're going to
assess your overall obligations and then
come up with a figure that they think is
manageable but frankly the bank doesn't
know all of the rest of what's going on
in your personal life they don't know
for example if you plan on maybe going
back to school or getting a graduate
degree they don't know if you might be
in the middle of a separation or a
divorce they don't know if you're
planning to have a baby or to add to
your family so you have to always take
into account not just the kind of nuts
and bolts in financial terms of what a
lending officer or a bank says that you
can afford but you have to also think
about the stuff that they don't know oh
and the bank won't ask you the stuff
that they don't know they will ask you
the basics around that and a lot of it
is frankly tied to what they actually
see on your credit report and so when it
comes to a whole host of other things
the bank doesn't know how frequently you
eat out every month and that's not
really their concern they don't know
whether or not you plan to travel in the
summer or at any given point during the
year they don't know what your holiday
gift giving or spending is like so all
of those other personal or lifestyle
expenditures and considerations really
do need to be taken into account when
you think about your overall cost of
living and how that might impact your
ability to buy and support a house over
the long term you know Lynette there's
one piece of economic data that buyers
and sellers focus in on and that's
mortgage rates so let's say someone is
setting out to buy their first home what
should they know about mortgage rates
well for 2023 obviously the big thing is
that rates are unfortunately On The Rise
now we've seen of course recent turmoil
in the banking sector and so nobody has
a crystal ball but what we can say
unequivocally is we saw rates initially
Peak back in October of 2022 right
around seven percent they've come down
now to maybe six and three quarters but
overall the expectation is of course
that rates are certainly far higher now
in 2023 than they were a year ago
substantially higher so given this you
need to be thinking about your own
economic circumstances and whether or
not you'd be comfortable getting into a
fixed rate mortgage that is going to be
kind of a plain vanilla 30-year set it
and forget it or whether or not you'd be
willing to hedge a little bit and to
consider an adjustable rate mortgage or
an arm and whether that's right for you
I think you should also be thinking
about the term of any loan that you
would consider certainly not just for
people who are buying but even those who
are refinancing you want to be thinking
about do I want to be in the traditional
30-year note or would a 20-year better
suit me or even a 15 year and again it's
going to be based on each individual's
circumstances and their budget now the
amount you're going to pay off depends
on how much money you've paid up front
the down payment and this is where the
affordability question often trips up a
lot of people how much money should a
home buyer be prepared to come up with
in a down payment well I certainly like
for people to understand that it's
absolutely not a requirement that you
come up with say a traditional 20 down
payment because a lot of people think
well geez I'm never going to be able to
afford a house if I had to save up you
know at that level especially given
Regional variations across the country
where we've topped 440 thousand dollars
or so Nationwide in terms of median home
prices
so if you thought about a 20 down
payment 88 000 maybe 90 000 would be
required but again that is not required
depending on the type of loan that you
get you can put down as little as three
and a half percent if you get a
government insured an FHA loan for
example but you do need to understand
what happens whether or not you go the
conventional mortgage route or the
government insured loan route and in
essence if you do put down anything less
than 20 percent then you're going to
have to pay mortgage insurance in the
form of a mortgage insurance premium or
PMI private mortgage insurance so you
can put down five percent you can put
down 10 percent many lenders will let
you put down 15 of course but if you
don't have at least twenty percent
equity when you're walking in the door
you will have to pay essentially a
surcharge every month in the form of
monthly insurance insurance
so those are some ways to figure out
what buying a home would cost you but
what if your finances aren't where they
need to be to make the numbers add up
we'll talk about how you can get your
financial house in order so you can buy
a real one
so you're thinking of buying a home
you've thought about a price range
you've started building up a down
payment but there's a lot more that goes
into how to afford a home than that
here's more from my conversation with
Lynette calfani Cox
now you mentioned a credit report
earlier the other important number in
all this for a lot of people is their
credit score how important is the credit
score really in the home buying process
your credit score is hugely important
when it comes to buying a home these
days so you absolutely want to make sure
that your FICO score is in Tip-Top shape
and what that means in terms of mortgage
lenders is at a minimum most want to see
a FICO score of 620 points or better
that's kind of like the bare minimum
that the cut off and again your FICO
score ranges from 300 a low of 300 and
we hope you're nowhere down near there
to as high as a perfect 850 FICO score
so 620 is a is about the minimum to get
a yes for most lenders
but then if you have a 700 or better
FICO credit score then you are deemed to
have good credit and you'll be able to
get good loan rates and terms
I always try to have people be in what I
call the perfect credit scoring range
which is really a 760 to an 850 FICO
scoring range and if you do fall into
that category banks are going to fall
all over themselves to do business with
you your credit union
Etc they will give you the very best
loan terms and rates that are available
in the marketplace well you know Lynette
people are dealing with a lot these days
inflation's pretty much torn a hole
through people's personal finances and
they might be struggling to keep their
credit score in that perfect range or
even close to it to get an ideal
mortgage rate what steps can they take
to maybe boost their credit score there
are a number of Fairly straightforward
steps that anyone can do to boost their
credit score and sometimes to do so
fairly quickly
one is if you're already a renter and
you have not yet made the leap to home
ownership you can add your rental
payment history to your credit reports
now you personally can't do this you
have to go through a third party to do
it but many consumers will find that
they get a 30 50 70 point jump or more
in their FICO credit score just from
adding this alternative Credit Data to
their credit files the credit files that
are maintained by the big three by
Equifax Experian and Transunion so
adding your rental payment history is
one way to boost your credit score you
can do it with other things too like
Utility payments and so forth
second you should obviously make sure
you focus on paying all your bills on
time every single month without fail the
number one factor in your FICO credit
score 35 percent of it is based on how
well you pay your bills on time and so
you never want to have any 30-day late
payments on your credit reports because
a single missed payment can drop your
FICO credit score by 50 to 100 points so
you absolutely never want to miss any
payments and then third I would say
lower your credit card balances so 30
percent of your FICO credit score is
based on the amount of debt that you
have outstanding specifically that
credit card debt that a lot of folks are
carrying so when you lower your credit
card balances that tends to boost your
FICO credit score and so whether you're
adding in your rental payments into the
formula to try to boost your score by
maybe 70 points maybe you've got some
late payments and you might lose 150
that point spread in your credit score
can be a real Difference Maker
absolutely I mean think about folks who
might be at the margins if you were at a
700 and you had a late payment for
example and you got dropped down to the
620 630 40 category now all of a sudden
you're in a different credit tier and A
lender is not going to give you good
interest rates so you really do want to
make sure you're paying those
obligations on time even being though at
a say a 720 if you have good credit and
you're able to boost your credit score
further Maybe by 40 points or so by
adding rent payment or other alternative
Credit Data to your credit report that
might put you in the very best of tiers
to get the optimal interest rates that
are available to consumers in the
marketplace so by all means do
everything in your power to boost those
credit scores
I would add also Jr that there's one
other uh technique that helps in Fairly
short order to boost one's FICO credit
score and that's a technique called
piggybacking and that's essentially
where you get added as an authorized
user on someone else's credit card
accounts we've done this with our adult
children who are in their early 20s
added them as an authorized user on our
credit cards that we've had say for 20
years and they benefit by essentially
kind of inherit if you will the the good
long paying track record in history that
my husband and I have on those cards are
our two older kids get the benefit of
that and that's boosted their credit
scores as well oh so sort of like
benefit by association absolutely that's
exactly how you could look at it all
right so you've got the down payment the
mortgage the insurance those are all big
expenses that can be the Difference
Maker when trying to buy a home but what
other expenses should people be aware of
to get a better picture of their ability
to buy a home well one of the biggest
challenges for people when it comes to
home ownership is that they've kind of
been taught that it's only about the
mortgage payment and that equals
affordability when nothing could be
further from the truth I have an
expression that I use where I say it's a
Pity that it's not just pity and what I
mean by that is it's a Pity it's a shame
that it's not just p-i-t-i principle
interest taxes and insurance in reality
there's everything from moving costs
which can be considerable to Furniture
to decorating a home to repairs to
upgrades to utility costs and more when
it comes to navigating the home
ownership process
so don't ever think for a moment that oh
I can afford the house payment I'm good
everything is going to be fine no every
homeowner can tell you you're going to
have to do some repair that was
unexpected you're going to have some
unanticipated cost whether it's Plumbing
that needs to be done electrical work a
leaky roof or something else which is
why it's a smart idea if you can swing
it to have a cash Reserve where you have
one two percent or so of the value of
your home put aside to deal with
emergencies repairs upgrades Renovations
other things that you might want to or
need to do to maintain and to keep your
home all right that's Lynette calfani
Cox founder and CEO of the money Coach
Lynette thanks so much for being with us
my pleasure Jr
and once you have your finances in order
it's time to find a home join us next
Friday for episode two of your money
briefings home buying Series where we'll
take a snapshot of the current housing
market how have falling mortgage rates
shifted the balance of power between
buyers and sellers and What's led us to
the current Nationwide housing shortage
we'll examine what you can expect and
what you need to know
and that's it for your money briefing
this week your money briefing was
produced this week by Ariana osparo this
episode was mixed by Jess Fenton our
supervising producer is Melanie Roy and
our executive producer is Chris zinsley
I'm your host J.R Whalen thanks for
listening and have a great weekend
[Music]